Oh top five where you been
yeah no you keeping up with all the
years lay some on me all right
Mass Effect Andromeda has a new patch
cuckoo touch 1.06 does a bunch of
different things including various
improvements that's what they've called
it the elusive various improvements to
our cinematics particularly in the
game's opening hours so should be
interesting to see what's changed what
you probably will notice has changed is
Sarah rather looks completely different
really yeah which a lot of people are
happy about because a character model
probably wasn't ace but some people are
upset about it because what they've done
is basically given her a makeover
she's got lipstick on now her hair is
super shiny you know people who've
played Andromeda now for like a hundred
hours just and picked a fault female
writer have just seen their character
appearance completely change but there
are other changes as well such as when
you're talking to NPCs and they've got
more to say the dialogue options weren't
grey out anymore so that's good you
won't miss out on things and there's
things like if you picked up either the
deluxe editions you get like some
freebies like skins and you outfit and
there's a multiplayer pack in there too
cool Eddy you better put that hood up
cuz I've got some Assassin's Creed news
for you Assassin's Creed origins looks
to be the 2017 entry in the franchise
the reports are saying it's potentially
set in Egypt which is a cool place they
have not gone to yet and I'm seems like
a lot of opportunity they're still early
days ps4 Xbox one PC most likely the one
image we saw was an off screen image so
not necessarily legit or we don't know
for sure at this point but it showed a
character on a boat which is smaller
than in Assassin's Creed 3 it looked
like he was on a river not sure where
he's going not sure what he's doing but
it's Seth Street so I'm sure we'll find
out very soon
any sad news this week square enix looks
like they're parting ways with the
developer of hitman I Oh interactive
they came out with a statement we could
investors saying that they are looking
to divest from IO Interactive to focus
more on key franchises and studios which
is kind of a bummer because hitman at
least 2016 here man was it was a really
good game absolutely and to our form
there's a potential you know season two
obviously have content coming up so like
all these things are in question now
yeah apparently Square Enix is looking
for an investor to take IO Interactive
but there's no guarantees if that's
going to happen but I'm hoping someone
picks them up cuz I want more hitman I
want to kill more famous 80 stars Gary
Busey get Nick Nolte in there Eddie
Murphy so laser goes on the list goes on
Eddie you're an American right I am
apparently only 11 percent of Americans
know what the hell project Scorpio is
what's the deal with that how can that
be that does not seem right well it kind
of makes sense Nielsen recently did a
console sort of awareness survey and
they discovered that only about 11% of
US general population knew or was aware
of go to Scorpio in terms of the other
consoles PlayStation 4 and Xbox one kind
of shared the most well-known status and
they hovered around 60 to 70 percent a
Nintendo switch and PlayStation 4 Pro
opened around 20% awareness but Scorpio
was the lowest right next to none of the
above before Spencer loosely came out
this week to say that everything's on
track we know a lot of hardware details
of Scorpio but that's kind of been
marketed towards the hardcore audience
and to make sure that people know that
Scorpio is going to be a big jump from
the regular Xbox but in terms of the
general sort of strategy that hasn't
really Connecticut giving you seem it's
going to start doing anything for sure
and I think another thing to point out
too is this survey was for a q1 yo
that's just January to March so still
very early before Microsoft even started
putting out those kind of teases about
the hardware so I think obviously a lot
of room to grow project Scorpio coming
up this holiday Microsoft hasn't
announced an official date but we've got
u3 right around the corner so we're sure
to find out that soon and then purchase
intent and awareness surely it will go
up after that only if you're interested
in Xbox fully expects to check out a
feature on GameSpot where we build a PC
based on the xbox Scorpio specs we come
see how it runs modern PC games checkout
throwing catching gold kickoff defense
you had an almost right except for goal
merit American football that's what I'm
good at that's what I know about EA
announced the cover star for Madden NFL
18 and it's none other than Tom Brady
the New England Patriots I'm from Boston
from the New England area so it's a very
big deal to me a lot of people hate him
he's a very polarizing figure but it's
not because he was married to a lovely
lady
he still is he still lives he's at the
wrong Brady though that was a Brady
Bunch reference we'll keep going so this
is the first time ever that it's been
two years in a row that a New England
Patriots player has been on the cover of
last year's Rob Gronkowski this year Tom
Brady obviously four-time Super Bowl MVP
five-time Super Bowl winner coming off
the incredible Super Bowl victory last
year so it's a kind of a no-brainer you
know tons of buzz already built in
there's going to be a goat edition so
greatest of all time is like that people
is what they call him that is going to
come out three days early so if you buy
that you get access to the game early
and if you're an exs member you get in
five days early too so there are
multiple ways to play early the game
comes out officially on August 25th but
yet Tom Brady is your cover star and
that has me excited and probably a lot
of people really angry so there'll be
the deflating the ball option in madam
2018 you need to check your sources on
that that's all for G s news top five
this week if you want more hot guys web
content and check out our preview on
side a straight review as well as yeah
sweet just we'll be back next Monday for
those of you have missed it although
downs doing a pretty good job so maybe
you should come back I don't know we'll
see you then
they come out with a statement to
investors saying that they've decided to
what's the word
they've decided to divest with a whiff
or dust from what does divest mean like
separate oh that makes sense
that makes sense